I think the advice that I would give
anyone looking to work in film or as a
production designer is to be really
honest about what you love I always tell
people that they really need to love it
know thyself figure out who you are what
motivates you what interests you learn
us a skillset that they could use to
find employment in an art department
that's just basic whether it's drawing
whether it's illustrating and learn to
draw learn to express themselves you
know verbally and and express themselves
on paper television series is a really
good experience to have because it
really often it'll teach someone how to
think on their feet learning as much as
you possibly can in higher education and
then you can master painting and you can
master architectural drawing on the side
if you want to and then have a good
skill to come into the discipline with
so that you can at least get a job and
observe production designers at work the
most important thing is to get sort of
as broad an education as you can get a
really well-rounded education early so
that you know a lot about a lot of
things I actually like the idea for a
production designer that they have a
university education and that they've
studied you know art architecture but
also literature and the history of art
history of design the history of
interior design the history of
architecture history of sculpture and
you should know Carl Jung you should
know Joseph Campbell you should know
architectural history you should know
contemporary architecture you should
know furniture design theater and drama
in English how to draw how to read how
to read a picture you should know you
should do it you know it is never-ending
each show is like this incredible
research project where we're trying to
become experts as fast as we can these
things require just a real intimate
knowledge of all sorts of things go have
adventures go travel the world go be
curious about everything about art and
architecture and cultural anthropology
and don't lose the curiosity travel look
at the choices people make in their
lives keep honing your skills but keep
experiencing life and the
Goldin somewhere along the way you'll
discover if you want to be a production
designer or not because I think you wind
up there because ultimately it's the
place you're supposed to go it's a
difficult career it takes a lot of
stamina I have the patience to do
thorough research ability to change
takes a lot of out of you in terms of
schedule you have to enjoy very long
hours because of the nature of the work
being on the road a lot ability to work
well with a lot of people be totally
collaborative you need to be able to be
creative and you need to be able to be
organized you have to be creative but
you have to be great with money not
fearful of making choices to listen
before you jump to a conclusion and just
barge right ahead and do something
understand the project as a whole but
not to try to think about it all at once
because the amount of things that you're
responsible for on a film are can be
quite overwhelming if you try to indulge
all of it at one time disaster strikes
daily kind of you know kind of as you
get more and more mature and more
experienced you can figure out how to
work yourself around that it's very
important to understand what the camera
sees and I think that means you really
have to have a good understanding of
camera and lens work and it's very
important to understand that the camera
is not the same as your eye and you have
to simplify things in a way that you can
interpret them
I was felt that I had to pick my path
and go towards it and that's not at all
how it happened my path evolved as I did
and I never could have guessed that I
would be a production designer
you